but we're going to begin with a winner
in the hotly contested Georgia Senate
runoff CBS News is now projecting that
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock will
keep his seat after a very hard-fought
race against Republican Herschel Walker
the Reverend Warnock invoked his faith
during a victory speech in Atlanta last
night Democrats will now have a 51-49
majority in the senate in January a
one-seat gain after many predicted that
Republicans could take control that did
not happen Nicole Killian is in Atlanta
with more on the story Nicole I saw them
they were celebrating big time at
Warnock headquarters last night I saw an
electric slide or two
there were quite a few years a big party
last night Gail and look Senator Warnock
won in part because he banked a lot of
early votes and he improved on his
performance in November defying the odds
by becoming the only Democrat to win
Statewide here in Georgia this election
cycle
as soon as the Georgia senate race was
called Tuesday night celebration erupted
Senator ralphia Warnock was projected to
win re-election to the U.S Senate thank
you from the bottom of my heart
and
and to God be the glory
joined by his family on stage that
Democratic incumbent was euphoric after
his victory against Republican
Challenger Hersha Walker earning a
congratulatory call from President Biden
after a hard-fought campaign
you've got me for six more years
warnock's name did not come up during
Walker's concession but the former
football star acknowledged it was game
over now I'm not going to make any
excuses now because we put up one heck
of a fight and I said that's what that's
what we got to do on both sides a mix of
emotions we felt wonderful uh we won we
did it again this closes the chapter on
the last Senate race of the 2022
midterms it was one of the most
expensive and controversial contest in
the country one thing I have not done
I've never pretended to be a police
officer
I am with many police officers Walker
was hand-picked by former president
Trump and is at least the fifth
trump-backed Senate candidate to be
defeated depriving Republicans of their
chance to win back the majority now with
Democrats in control warnocks win gives
the party an extra seat to help Advance
their agenda I'm ready to build a
stronger Georgia God bless you keep the
faith and keep looking up
Senator Warnock is expected to return to
Capitol Hill as soon as today Majority
Leader Chuck Schumer called his win the
last brick in Democrats firewall Nate
Nicole thank you